ونبقى في تونس معنا من هناك الكاتبه
والمؤلفه والباحثه الدكتوره الفا يوسف
دكتوره الفا يسعد صباحك اهلا بك معنا في
صباح العربيه ونتشرف باستضافه اليوم في
صباح العربيه اولا
صباح الانوار لك ولكل المشاهدات
والمشاهدين والشرف لي سيدتي والف مبروك
يقتضي حضور شاهدين من الرجال هذه السابقه
هل هي تمرد ام رساله معه
تكون الامور واضحه هذه ليست اول مره تشهد
فيها امراه على عقد الزواج في تونس لكن
ربما من المرات القلاء التي كان شهد
التالي امراتين وغابطه الحاله المدنيه
التي كتبت العقد امراه قانونيا ليس هناك
اي شيء يمنع من ان يكون الشاهد على عقد
الزواج امراه او رجل في تونس فالمواطن
والمواطنه لهما نفس الحقوق الواجبات
وكلاهما يدفع الضرائب للدوله وكلاهما
يشتغل ويطبق القوانين في هذه الحاله كان
هناك عروس وعريس يريدين ان يكرما امهما
وهنا هناك خلط في اذهان الناس كنت استمع
الى احاديث الجماعه كلمه العرف تكررت
والتربيه والعادات العادات ليست مقدسه
العادات هي اشياء يمكن ان نفكر فيها وان
يراجعها والدليل اننا في البلدان العربيه
الاسلاميه تقريبا جميعا لنا قدس خاصه للام
الجنه تحت اقدام الامهات نحب الامهات ندعو
الى كسبيناهم ولكن عندما يتعلق الامر بحفل
زواج مثل عقد الزواج تتاخر الام
يتقدم الاب همم
اشكال في عقود فيها الاب يكون شاهدا لكن
هنا العروسين هما نفسهما يعني الرجل
والمراه ابنتي وزوجها رغبه ان تكون
الشاهده هي الام هذا الشخص الذي يرعاهما
واهتم به الى اخره ليس هناك اي شيء يمنع
قانونيا ولا حتى شرعا لانه في الشرع
المعامله الماليه هي التي فيها مشكله رجل
رجل وامراتان وما الى ذلك وفيها اجتهادات
متعدده ليس هذا مجال حتى شرعا ابن تيميه
وغيره كثيرون
شهاده المراه في عقد الزواج ان نحن تاخرنا
كثيرا لطرح مثل هذه القضايا واعتبارها
امرا غريبا وعجيبا لو كان العقد فيه اربع
رجال يعني ضابط حاله مدنيه وشاهده والزوج
لما كان هناك اشكال ولا نتساءل الناس اين
المراه طب دكتوره الفا حضرتك كتبتي منذ
عقود وانت تتحدثين عن مساله المساواه بين
المراه والرجل هل تعتبرين بانك جسدتيها في
زفاف ابنتك
وحاول قدر الامكان ان اكون موافقه لما
اقول في افكارك وهذا ليس بسيطه لانه كل
المفكرين وجوليا المفكرين احيانا تجدهم
يقولون كلاما وفي حياتهم الشخصيه يمارسون
اقتناعات اخرى هذه المبادره الى جانب انها
كانت رغبه من ابنتي وزوج ابنتي هي بالنسبه
لي تشتيمون حي لما اؤمن به لاعتقاد العميق
ان المساواه هي جوهر الاخلاق وهي جوهر
مقاصد الشريعه الاسلاميه وهي جوهر التعايش
بين الرجل والمراه القائم على الموده
والرحمه وان يكون كلاهما عنصر فاعلا في
المجتمع دون اي صراع ودون تفضيلي همم جنس
على جنس دكتوره الفصه وقفنا يعني قلت رغبه
من ابنتي ورغبه من زوج ابنتي عندما طرحتهم
الفكره على اهل العريس ماذا كان موقفهم
ردت فعلهم في هذا الخصوص
ما اسعدني كثيرا هو ان اعاده وليس عاده في
كثير من العائلات لو طرحت هذه الفكره فاب
العريس وابى العروس وما الذي سينزعجان
ويقولان ماذا سيقول الناس عنا تركنا
زوجاتنا هن اللواتي يشهدن وما بين ذلك من
العقليات السائده في البلدان العربيه
بالعكس بالنسبه لهذه الحاله ساعدت بان
زوجي الذي اعرفه من زمان وهو ايضا كاتب
الاستاذ عادل الخضر وهو يؤمن بالمساواه
جسده هذا ايضا لم يكن له اي اشكال
يعني ابو زوج ابنته ايضا وافق بكل سرور
على هذا لكي يكون ذلك اجلالا للمراه والام
وبيانا ان لا معربه لشهاده المراه مع
القانون ولا معارضه لها مع الاخلاق ولا مع
الموده عندما تكون هناك موده والفه وحب
داخل الاسره هذه لتصبح اشياء ثانويه
يطرحها البعض ويجعلون منها مجال للجدل
والمساله كبرت جدا في تونس واتلقى رسائل
عديده تناقش وتحلل انا سعيده سعيده بان
طرح هذه المساله حتى نفكر فيها ونتبين كيف
ان العرف احيانا يقودنا الى اشياء لا
علاقه لها لا بالعقل ولا بالمنطق ولا
بالاخلاق ولا حتى باجتهادات متنوعه في
مجال الشرعيه
قال بان الحكايه هذه مره يعني بدون ضجه
كبرى في تونس في التحديد هل تعتقدين بانه
هذا مؤشر معطاء ايجابي نوعا ما هو في تونس
حقيقه منذ سنوات ومنذ حتى في القرون الوسط
لان الصديق القيرواني وما الى ذلك بسالك
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه مطروحه نعم
هناك تصدق الاجتماعي هناك خوف اجتماعي لان
هذه المساواه بدات فعلا تتجسم بنسبه كبيره
في الواقعه المساله تثير ضجه في الكلام
والحديث والحوار ولكن بما ان القانون وهو
الفيصل بين الناس يسمح بذلك فلا يمكن ان
يتعدى الكلام مجرد الجدل لذلك ادعوا دائما
فالان نفسه الى تطوير القوانين والى تطوير
العقليات يدا بيا وكل واحد يؤثر في الاخر
يعني في تونس القوانين المتقدمه جدا
القوانين المتقدمه اكثر العقليات ولكنها
تؤثر في العقليات
والاشتغال يجب ان يكون على المجالين
المجال القانوني التشريعي من جهه والمجال
الاجتماعي النفسي من جهه اخرى لان
العقليات تحتاج وقتا لتطور واين كنا واين
اصبحنا و هناك تطور كبير جدا والاولاد
استوجب قرون يعني نحن في حاجه الى نضال
مستمر حتى ترسخ هذه الفكره وبدات تنسخ شيء
الى الحديقه
يوسف شكرا لك